großer streiktag an den deutschen
flughäfen heute die lufthansa die ist
heute boden hansa 800 flüge sind
gestrichen 130 tausend passagiere
betroffen grund die piloten setzten sich
nicht ins cockpit die wollen mehr geld
ja direkt an die flughäfen also an die
großen lufthansa drehkreuze nach münchen
und nach frankfurt zunächst zu unserer
reporterin lisa gödert nach frankfurt am
main die meisten die heute flüge mit der
lufthansa gebucht hatten die sind gleich
zuhause geblieben
genau so scheint es zumindest also die
leute die hier ankommen und dann
schockiert vor der tafel hier stehen
bleiben wo quasi jeder zweite flug
gecancelt ist mittlerweile das sind
leute die englisch sprechen die aus
australien kommen oder aus kanada und
die einen stopover haben hier und jetzt
nicht mehr weiter kommen und die die
sitzen fest in frankfurt am main bis
morgen vermutlich oder kann relativ
schnell unkompliziert auf andere
airlines umgebucht werden
also dass lufthansa personal an den
schaltern ist ja hier vor ort das heißt
das hilft den leuten dann auch läutet
sie zumindest weiter zu anderen
schaltern wo man versucht sie auf einen
flug einer anderen airline umzubuchen
damit sie zumindest weiterreisen können
für alle die hier stecken bleiben gibt
es auch einen versorgungsstaat von der
lufthansa da gibt es snacks und säfte
wie dieser hier das ist kein tomatensaft
es ist sommer kirsch zitrone aber ja ein
kleiner ersatz ein kleiner trost für den
tomatensaft denen es an bord dann wohl
gegeben hätte es ist dann doch
ja ich weiß jetzt die ganzen passagiere
130000 sind betroffen sich von seiner
sucht kiste trösten es reicht wenn wir
aus australien kommt eine durstlöscher
direkt nach münchen zu philipp hacke
menden auch münchen betroffen von diesem
riesigen streit bei der lufthansa heute
alles stillsteht die piloten wollen mehr
geld wie wird sich das jetzt auf den
flughafen münchen aus großer flughafen
hier in deutschland viel bewegung drin
an diesem freitag was hast du dort
beobachtet
ja du sagst es ist der zweitgrößte
flughafen in münchen fertig
normalerweise über 100.000 passagiere
pro tag ab und heute ja heute ist hier
mehr oder weniger gähnende leere es gibt
hier im terminal 2 noch einige partner
airlines der lufthansa die fliegen aber
bei der lufthansa sind über die hälfte
der flüge gestrichen und deshalb sehen
wir auch hinter uns relativ wenig los es
gibt noch am umbuchungsschalter hier
einige passagiere die stehen und
versuchen ihre flüge kurzfristig
umzubuchen aber die meisten haben
vermutlich schon in den letzten tagen
von der lufthansa per e mail ihre infos
bekommen und haben entsprechend entweder
schon umgebucht oder sitzen jetzt hier
in münchen fest für die passagiere die
in deutschland reisen also die zum
beispiel von münchen nach berlin
geflogen wären die können ihr flugticket
jetzt als fahrschein bei der bahn
einlösen aber für alle die eine weitere
strecke jetzt vor hatten die sitzen
entweder fest oder hatten vielleicht
noch glück auf einer der wenigen um
buchungsmaschinen zu kommen philipp
hagemann dieser goethe vielen herzlichen
dank für eure informationen von den
flughäfen frankfurt und münchen
die piloten streiken und 130 passagiere
bleiben ja und jetzt direkt zu einem der
uns diese streiks mit eingebrockt hat
matthias beyer von der
pilotengewerkschaft cockpit grüße sie
hat sich bei bild live jetzt gerade
genau so formuliert so werden dass
nämlich heute ganz ganz viele passagiere
empfinden sie sitzen dort auf dem sofa
und sind überzeugt davon dass der streik
trotzdem richtig ist
nun zunächst muss man mal festhalten wer
hat den streicher eingebracht wir haben
zehn tage lang verhandelt und dort ist
kein unlock sich das angebot vorgelegt
worden so dass hier am ende dann nur
noch der arbeitskampf bleibt man muss
verstehen dass gilt der deutsche
beamtenbund hier schon uns die
solidaritätsbekundung mit wem hat ebenso
wie die unabhängige flugbegleiter
organisation auch eine gewerkschaft
tarifverträge auf augenhöhe setzen den
arbeitskampf voraus insofern ist vor
allem das streikrecht eine unerlässliche
institution der tarifautonomie
allerdings ist das recht kein keine
pflicht das heißt die luft unser hätte
diesen streik noch verhindern können
durch ein angebot das verhandlungssicher
ist das ist leider nicht geschehen und
das ist jetzt geldes resultat jetzt muss
man eher sagen dass piloten nicht
schlecht verdienen wir haben mit zum
teil je nachdem wie lange sie auch dabei
sind ein richtig richtig gutes gehalt
warum jetzt zu diesem zeitpunkt die
lufthansa muss man sagen würde es jetzt
gar nicht mehr geben hätte die nicht
ordentlich hilfe bekommen von der vom
staat in der korona krise jetzt also
dann dir diese rechnung aufmachen sagen
wenn wir da bei diesen dicken deutlich
mehr bekommen dann bleiben halt am boden
nun ist sind zwei aspekte die sie jetzt
ins spiel gebracht haben der eine ist
der vergütungstarifvertrag der lufthansa
ist am 30.06 ausgelaufen so das ist ganz
normal ist dass man jetzt erstmal in
terry fahndung geht sind zehn runden
gewesen und dauert gab es kein ergebnis
dass das natürlich einen trifft okay
dafür habe ich verständnis dass dann die
gut aber auch noch bei den passagieren
wo kommt dafür habe ich auch großes
verständnis allerdings ist dann
arbeitskampf natürlich immer damit
verbunden dass jemand betroffen ist das
ziel dieses arbeitskampfes ist aber
nicht die passagiere zu treffen sondern
lufthansa klar und deutlich zu
vermitteln es ist zeit für ein neues
angebot jetzt hat man sie noch gesagt
die kollegen verdienen ja bereits doch
ganz ordentlich ja das kann man so sehen
lufthansa ist natürlich ein guter zahler
von gehältern hier egal da auch im
cockpit nur mit einem tarifvertrag der
zu ende gelaufen ist hat man jetzt die
möglichkeit sich nach oben zu verhandeln
ja das ist etwas wirklich alle aus
gehaltsverhandlungen man möchte nach
oben fahren will ja nur der punkt ist
wenn man dann natürlich als pilot wenn
man lange dabei ist bei der lufthansa
und man verdient irgendwie in richtung
der viertel million pro jahr und man
legt das jetzt gegen die die gerade eben
keine gehaltserhöhung bekommen gegenüber
den millionen deutschen und die sich
einen kleinen urlaub abgespart haben und
jetzt fest sitzen am flughafen die
empfinden das natürlich als brutal
ungerecht
das kann ich verstehen wenn man das
vergleicht mit einander nur diese zahlen
dieser gerne hier genannt werden sie
sagten gerade
das sind natürlich gehälter die
erreichen sie nur nach einer langen
karriere wenn sie überhaupt da hinkommen
mit einer jagger zulage oder trainings
kapitäns zulage das ist ja nicht
garantiert sie fangen viele früher und
viel niedriger steigen sie einfangen sie
viel früher an und
dann steigert sich das nach und nach und
darf auch nicht vergessen dass natürlich
die ausbildung einen gewissen teil
kostet den sie auch selbst zu tragen
haben und
noch mal wir haben die
solidaritätsbekundung vom deutschen bank
unter ufo unsere forderung mit der
forderung nicht alleine ich verstehe
dass ihr das nochmal untermauern ich
möchte aber doch auch noch mal die
sorgen der menschen untermauern einen
punkt nämlich bei diesen verhandlungen
die lufthansa ist in den verhandlungen
ja auch schon auf sie zugekommen es gab
nicht dass den fall dass da gar keine
zugeständnisse gab einen punkt
interessiert mich jetzt wollen die
piloten dass ihr gehalt mehr oder
weniger codierten sie mich sehr gerne an
die inflation angepasst wird also ist
man sagt inflation kommt ja und je nach
dem müssen wir uns dann auch weiter
steigern das hat einfach niemand wo
gibt's denn sowas kennt quasi das nach
oben offenes gehalt verhandeln wenn ich
aus einer gut bezahlten situation kam
nicht pandemie bedingt in den letzten
jahren nicht überarbeitet habe sie sagen
selber sie haben verständnis für die
menschen die so was ärgert ihr das nicht
verstehen kann hier drückt die
frustriert sind über sowas wenn ihr
verständnis so groß ist dann machen sie
es doch nicht
also dass die inflation die dazu führt
dass die arbeit die gleiche arbeit
nächstes jahr dann weniger wert ist das
ist glaube ich bei jedem der davon
betroffen ist und das sind ja nahezu
alle arbeitnehmer ja leider eher ein hof
problem und dass man versucht das durch
einen tarifvertrag hier zu kompensieren
das ist die forderung lage was am ende
dabei rauskommt dass wenn wir dann sehen
wenn die beiden nicht verteilen die
aufeinander angewiesen sind sich wieder
zusammensetzen und am ende ein ergebnis
finden können dann kann matthias bayer
verdienten vereinigung cockpit nahm sie
die lufthansa schnellstmöglichst wieder
der lufthansa und nicht zu boden hansa
danke
[Musik]